well most political campaigns sell tacky
t-shirts that nobody wants
what is Trump campaign selling and
attitude in the form of recyclable
plastic straws since the campaign
tweeted making straws great again the
first batch of a hundred and forty
thousand sold out that's 200 grand in
sales now you can call this silly or
mean but it's really pretty hilarious
the Trump straw targets key liberal
weaknesses their strident humorless Ness
and misplaced priorities and pokes him
right in the eyes the crusade to ban
plastic straws has yet more proof of how
liberals try to distract us from the
harm they've done to our cities our law
enforcement our job markets and our
border maybe no one will notice what
they did to the humans of downtown LA
and other democratic hell halls if they
save a turtle from a straw yep an actual
headline said someday a turtle may end
up with a trump branded straw in its
nose Wow who knew reptiles did coke so
Trump saw this absurd crusade is a
perfect opportunity for the new
Republican Party one that finally
understands the power of fun and the
muscle of mockery long the turf solely
owned by the smirking left of scripts
been flipped it's now the left whose
shriek like nosy neighbors and the right
who are laughing out loud the paper
straw is a perfect symbol of failed
soggy replacement for something that
worked just fine a paper straw is
socialism to capitalism sturdy plastic
how funny is it that the straws purpose
is to suck so you think the left would
do that well wrong they even suck at
sucking I have to say that Trump might
be the first president what is the first
president history to galvanize trolling
for fun and profit yeah right
yeah so the campaign manager for Trump
2020 bad parse Cal tweeted last week
that he's so over paper straws hashtag
liberal progress this is exactly what
they would do to you at the economy as
well squeeze it until it doesn't work
they started selling real straws to
raise tons of money which this is the
reaction right like when you go so far
to the left and you tell people they
can't do something they're going to
continue doing doing it and in the most
role worthy
way possible and to make a campaign
donation to buy real straws I would do
that what other things one should they
sell lawn darts to listen because I'm
gonna give President Trump some credit I
think he is just genius at getting
people to separate themselves from their
fear we're gonna take your guns now
we're gonna take your straw you can mock
the Liberals oh yeah that's great
mocking people it's fun it's now
described this fun it's not like you
know Rudin is silly and ridiculous it's
fun so go right ahead to me you know I
just think the Bible says you know we
should be good stewards of the earth and
now oh no don't pay attention to that
just go ahead do whatever it was the
Bible printed on yeah degrees those poor
trees Jesse Greg I'm gonna have to agree
with one on this okay and here's why I
get that he's tapped into the zeitgeist
so this is a brilliant marketing plan to
raise a lot of money Turtles that's fine
I'm not like on a plastic straw jihad
but we will eventually phase out plastic
straws and here's why okay here the top
in the top ten most polluted items on
the world's beaches and they clog up the
streams and the waterways and lakes and
the rivers and oceans because they're so
thin like I don't get collect it up it's
not so when I'm on a [ __ ] I don't want
to see a straw I want a body surf
without straws I want to tan without
straws I'm like no you do too
when i fish because the fish eat the
straws and then they die I want to eat
the fish before they die I think we can
all agree on this now that paper straws
are better for the environment and they
don't disintegrate what about how long
we take to - sipping iced coffee
within hours it's over last like a
second they don't work for me hold on
wait they try to give you metal straws
yes what they chip your dam that works
for you
so unless many Church there quickly
medicare-for-all give it in there yep
unless Mary
my veneers I mean I'm done my drink let
me lick dag and talk be good tonight let
me throw to the president talking about
this and then we'll get a response okay
let's do that I do think we have bigger
problems than plastic straws you know
it's interesting about plastic straws so
you have a little straw but what about
the plates the wrappers and everything
else that a much bigger and they're made
of the same material so the straws are
interesting everybody focuses on the
straws there's a lot of other things to
focus in but it's an interest it's an
interesting question you know dig in The
Washington Post wrote a piece you know
saying like you know this is gonna arm
Turtles their paper cut their newspaper
often comes in a plastic container yeah
you know it's hypocrisy all around it is
hypocrisy
I love the liberal lunacy and say San
Francisco that bans plastic straws but
the city is covered in human excrement
right that's not just the stench of
sanctimonious smells you're walking
around San Fran and just one other thing
at the beaches you know it's a bigger
problem than plastic straws I don't know
cigarette butt candy wrappers beer cans
condoms okay so get rid of those with
you because I'm going on vacation I
don't want to like junk on the beach he
can sell everything he says what about
the plan what about globs plastic oh I
love plastic I do term it does I'm say
I'm gonna have a lot of it my face so I
love it even more is that that's the
riddle IRA do is when you see liberal
celebrities arguing against plastic as
they shoot Botox into their face I'm
really worried about four isn't it yes
all right